Hello
bitches.
You know,
one of the things when we were talking
about that I think is kind of important,
like when you're talking about um,
immigration and like bad
apples and stuff like that.
I look at immigration as same way.
I look at gun control.
Like most people that have guns are law
abiding citizens and it's not going to
be a problem. The vast, vast majority,
and I think that's the same case with
immigration and the same case of people
coming to America, even the
illegally, they want to do better.
That's why they're coming here.
They're not coming here because they
want to start crying. Sure. They,
most of them are coming here
because they want opportunity.
It's with guns.
I totally agree.
I want a shotgun so badly
when I needed a double barrel,
like I don't want to shotgun and I'm,
I've shot a lot of guns should,
especially with the daily show,
I've done shot guns for the daily show.
You guys going to be telling jokes?
Going to have to learn how to fucking
clear room out and defend yourself. Okay.
All right. Now, this is a
Thompson machine gun discipline.
Very important for the daily Cheryl,
not 50 caliber sniper busters.
50 calibers are ridiculous.
Dude, I will show you
a video after this. Uh,
actually maybe this hasn't really even
aired because it was part of a pilot that
I did that did. I did a pilot for comedy
central when I left the daily show.
It was an anti travel show
called displaced sucks.
I didn't go, dude, I'll send it
to you. Great idea. Just the con
dude. It's the fucking funny. You
know what they said? What you mean?
Everybody said it was too mean.
It's fucking hilarious. I go,
we stayed in Kansas City. I go, hey
everybody, my name is Al Madrigal.
I'm in Kansas City. I'm going to
tell you why this place sucks.
Just shit all over it and it just,
just do that online. Oh yeah.
I should just put them out 20 minutes.
A great idea for all things comedy.
Why don't you just like buy or make idea?
I totally just do you own the idea?
My idea? Oh my God, that's
a great idea. So that idea,
like as soon as you set it up,
you know,
someone says an idea and a light
bulb goes off, easy show, real id.
And I do it and see it.
Francisco
and I'd do it to San
Francisco is fucking filthy.
It is one of the dirtiest cities I've
ever been through in my entire life.
And also it's like filled with rich
douche bags now because of the, you know,
Internet boom.
And then all of this tech boom and
the poor people are getting moved out.
There's so much stuff to make fun
of. So anyway, I'm hate kind of a,
I went to this place oh and be
guns and I shot and machine guns,
handguns, like a shot, everything.
And then for the daily show I went
and I saw it was, I drove a tank,
I got to drive tanks. I was doing this
chieftain tanks that I was driving.
I got to run over to Saturn's in a tank.
Really? Yeah. It's fucking awesome.
How do you drive a tank? Like,
what do you, what do you not, yeah,
it's levers and there's uh, so
um, yeah, you could watch it.
And there was this hot chick that they
had that was working there that was on it
with me and at the same place
I got to fire machine guns,
but I feel like when it comes to automatic
weapons and a 50 caliber sniper and
all that shit, I don't understand
why you need to own that.
I liked shooting it. I'll go shoot
that stuff again. I really enjoyed it.
He couldn't see me shoot
that 50 caliber thing.
Like there was a shockwave or yeah,
like your,
your head flies but you couldn't watch
my arms and the skin on my arms ripple
after I fucking hurt cause I,
I wore a sleeveless shirt to shoot it.
Boom. Wow. And uh, I enjoyed it.
I liked shooting that shit and I want
the shotgun to defend my house when
everything goes to hell. Yes.
I'm be apocalypse and a shotgun.
I want just somebody to here
get the fuck away from the door.
You know what I have by my bed right now?
Hammers Hammer.
I have a hammer,
like bill makes fun of me.
Like he thinks it's the craziest thing.
Like you keep it by your bed.
I keep a hammer under my bed,
like I'm going to fucking
get up and close in contact.
Like hammered somebody's death. Yeah.
And it seems like you thought it through,
like really,
really like on a surface level.
I have a magnum flashlight and I can't
fly magnum flashlight. Yeah. Peter,
that always kills me when people
think they're going to clubs.
Somebody with flashlight. No, no, I
want to, I'm a flashlight in one hand.
So blind them and then fucking
running. Hammer. Hammer.
Why not a real weapon? I want
a real one. I got knives.
I have all close contacting me.
Never got a gun on my wife so I can oh,
one of them. Yep. Hmm. Well
I'll get one. I'm working on
her. She's good. She gets it.
Yeah. We've got to do as a false
flag in the house. Hire some friends.
[inaudible] oh yeah,
that's a good idea.
Not False flag. Really. The Dick Cheney
of households. Oh my God. So, um,
yeah I want the gun badly. But I feel
like with an AK 47 and maybe you know,
people can write like only bad
things have happened. People,
you know,
a district is responsible gun owners.
But you look at Dylan roof
and you look at, you know,
column when you look at all these people
getting shot up everywhere and seeing
the hook, like I don't want that
to happen. I don't want my kids.
I was walking away safe.
You put your guns in a safe.
Why do you need an AK 47 you don't need
an AK 47 I'm saying and have all the
handgun. But the thing is like who
should be able to decide who gets what.
That's where it gets weird. Yeah.
And what about silencers to, well,
here's the thing.
In,
in Europe silencers are thought of as
a polite thing because we're over in
America worried about shooting people.
They're worrying about noise.
So like if you have what they call
suppressor, they call suppressor.
Like if you're hunting,
you would hunt with a
suppressor on because you don't
want to blow your fucking
ears out.
Man,
I'll put the links out to these two
pieces that I did a daily show spots.
I'll do the one. If you go to my
thing, that Twitter, uh, I'll, uh,
I'll put it on.
I'll send them to you though when I
drove a tank and fired all those guns.
And then I did a silencer piece as well.
And the guy was saying he wanted to
protect kids ears with the silencers.
And that's what Donald Trump jr
saying kids. And I'm worried.
The reality is though,
and this is true,
I know a lot of friends that are hunters
that shot guns as kids and they're
fucked up now. They're ears
are a mess. Would it, should
they wear the, they should,
but they didn't when they were younger
because they didn't know any better. See,
20 years ago,
people didn't know that you were going
to do permanent damage to your ear.
They didn't, you didn't need ever heard
about it like these people just shotguns.
But I think also the,
uh,
unfortunate reality now is that you
could have somebody walking around
undetected shooting fucking shooting
people in a college and you could call it,
yeah,
I did.
I was on Kcrw and walking around the Santa
Monica campus and I really did think,
I'm like, okay, who's the
shooter? Right. Coast water.
And then it shouldn't be a thought
that, oh no, it shouldn't. Yeah.
I mean it's a mental health issue,
but because like the only person that's
capable of doing that as a person who's
sick. Yeah. You know,
and that's the other thing that doesn't
come up when you're talking about mass
shootings is whenever you hear
about it, the news, no one,
he makes the correlation,
the inescapable correlation between
psychoactive drugs and mass shootings
because there's a lot of
fucking mass shooters.
Like almost all of them that are either
on pharmaceutical drugs like SSR,
i's disassociative drugs,
or they're getting off of
'em antipsychotic drugs.
There's a look and be done is you're like,
there is no common ground.
He started having people make,
we live in this country where you
should be able to do whatever you want,
uh, and have whatever you want. But then
who gets to decide? Who gets questioned?
What guns?
Well,
Texas has sort of taking the idea
that just everybody has a gun,
a wheel armed society is a polite society.
My Ron white all of a sudden,
and then teachers should have guns in
the classroom and bulletproof helmets,
full vests. Jesus. Ak 47 is
right there, right there.
Put down the chalk. I don't know,
man. It sucks. Yeah, it's actually,
you have to think about it. There's
no easy solution. Yeah. Well it just,
every time one of those things happens,
everybody buckles down and wants to
take away guns and try to figure out
legislation.
And I just feel like the root of the
problem is not the tools that people are
using. It's the fact that someone's
willing to use those tools.
The fact that someone
is willing to do that,
the fact that those guns are more
accessible is a g is a genuine issue.
But I think we can all agree that no
one came for the guns. Uh, Obama. Every,
it's like Obama's coming for the guns.
What do you know why he knows the NRA,
the NRA is too strong.
The lobbies to strong,
they've spent a shit load of money and
continue to spend a shitload of money to
make sure they protect the
second amendment rights.
But so you're saying if they will,
if not for the NRA,
it 100%
per second.
All the guns,
they would have definitely done
something similar to what Australia did.
Australia essentially made gun
ownership very, very, very difficult.
They took away guns,
they enact a very strict laws and they
had like one mass shooting a long time
ago.
They're big mass shooting a long time ago.
That's the thing that they don't have
is like these big mass shootings,
you know when you see.
But Australia has the same amount of
people's California and it's the size of
the United States. Yeah.
They just just saw the thing.
There was a map comparisons
and fill your mind.
It's like it's the exact same size.
Yeah, it's crazy. And people are spread.
It's way spread out and it's the same
amount of people is Los Angeles and it's
in this giant ass fucking country.
So when you think about being able
to take people's guns in Australia,
it's different.
The culture is different.
The idea of independence
is different over there.
We have a different attitude over here.
Yeah. I just don't want to one. Yeah.
When you have little kids again,
she's your course changes, you know,
and she's like,
I don't ever,
why worry about them growing up in a
society where a teacher does have to think
about wearing a fucking helmet.
Of course, of course. I mean,
nobody wants to think that. I don't know
what the solution is, but the solution,
look getting the guns
away from the people.
There's more guns and there are human
beings in America and they're not,
they're not going to stop making
guns. No. It was good business. Yeah.
I the guns of the problem. I really
don't. I mean I support gun ownership.
I really do. I just started. I
don't think that's the issue.
I think the issue is lucky that we saw
in France in Nice that some crazy fucking
take a car and kill a hundred people
by plowing over Pete and just starts
stabbing people to get out of the car
and just fucking starts stabbing folks.
There's,
there's ways that people lose their
fucking minds and do horrible things to
people and the ways are not
things you have to take away.
You have to figure out a way. And I
don't go ale hammers. No. Right. Yeah.
I don't know what the solution is,
but I don't think anybody does the
idea of you see all those guns,
I think what you're getting at with
the mental health stuff is there,
I'm not opposed to there being a
screening process and seeing if you have a
history of violence. Of
course. Yeah. And uh,
if you are a show up on a terrorist watch
list and that's where I think the NRA
goes overboard. It's like if you're
on a fucking terrorist watch list,
who doesn't agree with that?
Well,
the only problem with that is who gets
to decide who's on the terrorist watch
list? Because there was people
that were, um, from, uh,
the Green party that were put on
terrorist watchlist after nine 11,
because they were anti war protesters
and they were put on no fly list.
There was a lot of weird shit that
happened where people were put on lists
because they pissed off the wrong people.
And you know,
in 2001 it was way easier to do something
like that, but it is to do it today.
Go to buy a gun and then they say,
I'm sorry he can't purchase this
weapon because you're on that list.
And then you can go to a gun
show that's part of the problem.
Go to a gun show and you could buy a gun
far easier and Kansas City and tighten
that down though. Kansas, Kansas,
you can go and Poop, correct me,
I'm wrong,
is
did a show called this place sucks.
What am I?
And so you go to Kansas and
then you can get a gun with,
no,
you don't do,
you get into just an Id Kansas Id and you
can get it in maybe like five minutes,
zero train. It's nothing,
just you get it right away.
You don't have to have a background
check. So true. Yes. Was that true?
Like when you did in 2014
when I did this piece? Yeah.
But you can look at Queen Queen,
check that gun laws Kansas. Come on.
No background check. No background
check. I'm pretty certain.
So why wouldn't you have to scan it in
Kansas and this kind of does with his
grandma. He walks into
this place and he goes, uh,
I can't even,
the guys says I can't buy the gun,
but she can make that he buys these
four guns or sub saying kills a bunch of
people.
So
Federal Law requires federally licensed
firearms dealers but not private sellers
to initiate a background check
on the purchase purchaser
prior to sale a firearm.
As a result,
concealed weapons license holders in
Kansas are exempt from the federal
background check requirement. Yeah, that's
crazy. No training. No background check.
Hold on.
A second.
Concealed weapons license holders like
you have to have a concealed weapons
license, which is difficult
to acquire. And let me,
it's not easy to get a concealed weapons
license unless they have a different
law. Their background checks and cans,
it's concealed way, but I think he could.
Concealed weapons is like the hardest
thing to get is a concealed carry.
Federal law provides states with
the options of serving a state.
Kansas has no law requiring
firearms dealers to initiate
background checks prior
to transferring a firearm.
As a result in Kansas,
firearms dealers must initiate the
background check required by federal law,
by contacting the FBI directly.
Kansas is not a point of contact state.
Huh.
So they have to contact the FBI.
Federal law does not require dealers to
conduct a background check of a firearm
purchase or presents a state permit
to purchase or possess firearms.
It meets certain conditions.
So it seems like there's definitely
some wiggle room. Yeah, yeah, for sure.
And then you know,
that's her,
he was talking about these gun shows
where you can just go gobble up a bunch of
firearms. They can't,
they can bring them into,
that's what they just transport
them across state lines.
And it's one of those things,
like many human issues where there's
not a whole lot of like clear paths.
It's like there's so many guns.
You're never going to take
them all away from people.
And should you take them all away from
him? Like if a guy like you as a gun,
I don't feel like no danger or a threat
unless you get in one of your God damn
tirades he might have another best example
that's fucking stealing wood.
So
did you hear that bit like a,
not a bit of video of Carlos [inaudible]
was on Joey Diaz a show saying they
thought about bringing a gun around and
going to the comedy store and shooting
people and he was carrying a gun in
his car and like, no, no, I'm crazy.
Well, there maybe you shouldn't
never gone. Yeah, he's
[inaudible].